hablemos un poco sobre reproducción tal
vez si nos vamos a otros planetas
encontremos nuevas formas en las que los
organismos se pueden reproducir pero en
el planeta tierra hay dos formas
principales en las que los organismos se
pueden reproducir para explicar la
primera supongamos que este es algún
tipo de organismo unicelular que hace
una copia de sí mismo ahí está y aquí
tenemos otra copia ahora en esta
situación podemos decir que todos tienen
un material genético idéntico supongamos
que este es el material genético del
primer organismo esta es una de sus
copias y aquí tenemos la otra a este
tipo de reproducción en donde un
organismo por sí mismo puede convertirse
en dos organismos se conoce como
reproducción asexual reproducción
asexual es decir que no es sexual así
que nuestra siguiente pregunta es qué es
la reproducción sexual bueno eso es
cuando dos organismos
células provenientes de dos organismos
necesitan unirse para poder producir a
un tercer organismo vamos a decir que
aquí tenemos la célula de uno de los
organismos supongamos que esta célula
proviene de la madre así que puede ser
un óvulo y aquí vamos a poner la célula
del otro organismo vamos a decir que
proviene del padre así que puede ser un
espermatozoide entonces cuando el óvulo
y el espermatozoide se unen es decir se
fusionan este organismo ahora contiene
la información genética de los dos
padres y así es como esta célula nueva
se convierte en la descendencia su hijo
si la reproducción sexual te suena
familiar eso es porque así fuiste
concebida pero para que esto sea más
tangible analicemos algunos casos de
reproducción asexual y reproducción
sexual aquí podemos ver un diagrama de
reproducción asexual conocida como
fisión binaria o también conocida como
bipartición
la palabra ficción se refiere a que algo
se divide y cuando las personas se
hablan de fisión nuclear se refieren a
la división del hato pero la afición
binaria se refiere a que un organismo se
divide en dos y como podemos ver si
tenemos este material genético ese
material genético se replica y el
organismo se divide en dos organismos
idénticos o al menos idénticos desde el
punto de vista genético la fisión
binaria o bipartición se aplica a las
procariotas de las que hablamos en otros
vídeos que son organismos que no tienen
organelos tampoco tienen membrana
nuclear y no tienden a tener múltiples
cromosomas pero si hablamos de las
eucariotas éstas sí tienen membranas
nucleares y múltiples cromosomas así
como organelos unidos a membranas en las
eucariotas podemos observar un tipo de
reproducción sin mirar
aquí tenemos la mitosis que la
estudiaremos con mayor profundidad en
otros vídeos esta es la mitosis y la
podemos ver como análoga a la fisión
binaria solamente que ahora lidiamos con
células eucariotas que como son más
complejas hacen que este proceso sea más
complejo pero a un nivel superior
también se puede considerar un tipo de
reproducción asexual en estos dos casos
podemos ver que una célula u organismo
según corresponda se convierte en dos
organismos que tienen la misma
información genética y es importante
mencionar que cuando se tiene un
organismo y se produce otro organismo
con la misma información genética a eso
se le conoce como clon tal vez estén
familiarizados con el término clon por
las películas de ciencia ficción por
ejemplo en la guerra de las galaxias'
cuando hablan de la guerra de los clones
todos esos clones tienen la misma
información genética del
cazarrecompensas original
tal vez la mitosis también sea familiar
para ustedes porque así es como se
divide la mayoría de las células en
nuestro cuerpo y así es como crecemos y
pasamos de ser un organismo unicelular a
uno multi celular
tal vez estén un poco confundidos a
estas alturas porque les acabo de decir
que la mayoría de nuestras células han
experimentado o están experimentando la
mitosis pero también son el resultado de
la reproducción sexual pero como veremos
en un momento tan pronto como ocurre la
reproducción sexual
esta célula nueva se convierte en un
organismo multicelular a través de la
mitosis pero también conforme crecemos y
nos desarrollamos nosotros también
producimos lo que se conoce como gametos
y cada gameto contiene la mitad de
nuestra información genética en los
seres humanos esto sería el óvulo
producido por la mujer y este es el
espermatozoide producido por el hombre
cuando se juntan el espermatozoide
fertiliza al óvulo y produce en una
célula viable que se puede convertir en
su descendiente en su hijo y bueno
retomando el concepto de la fisión
binaria existe otro tipo de reproducción
asexual en donde una célula madre
produce un brote
es una célula más pequeña y nuevamente
como en la fisión binaria tienen que
replicar todo el adn para que ese adn
quede insertado en la célula hija pero
al final se tiene una célula grande y
una pequeña podemos decir que la célula
pequeña brotó de la célula grande por
eso a esto se le conoce como germanio la
afirmación es otra forma de reproducción
asexual ahora cuando pensamos en los
organismos multicelulares existen
diferentes tipos de reproducción asexual
por ejemplo las estrellas de mar son
famosas por su habilidad para formar un
organismo nuevo a partir de una parte
original de otro por ejemplo supongamos
que se corta esta parte de la estrella
de mar para muchas especies de estrellas
de mar ese pedazo puede crear una
estrella de mar nueva y la estrella de
mar original hace crecer esa parte que
le falta este tipo de reproducción se
conoce como fragmentación fragmentación
es muy fácil de recorrer
se toma un fragmento y crece formando un
organismo nuevo así es como se reproduce
otro tipo de reproducción asexual
fascinante se conoce como partenogénesis
vamos a ver aquí tenemos un organismo
que es un dragón de komodo bebé y este
organismo se puede desarrollar a partir
de un óvulo no fertilizado recordemos
que en la reproducción sexual hablamos
de cómo un espermatozoide proveniente
del organismo del padre tiene que
fertilizar un óvulo en el organismo de
la madre y una vez que se fusionan el
óvulo fertilizado produce un organismo
multicelular mediante la mitosis pero en
la partenogénesis tiene un óvulo que no
necesita ser fertilizado y por sí solo
se puede convertir en un organismo
multicelular como este dragón de komodo
bebé pero tal vez se pregunten cómo es
eso posible bueno muchas veces este tipo
de óvulos no tienen la mitad del
material genético como ocurre en el caso
de los óvulos de la reproducción sexual
la partenogénesis el óvulo generalmente
contiene un conjunto completo de
información genética y puede comenzar la
mitosis para convertirse en un organismo
o también pueden existir situaciones en
donde el óvulo tiene la mitad de la
información genética hablaremos de esto
en otros vídeos en este caso esta sería
una célula a floyd y solamente contiene
la mitad de la información genética de
su padre o madre pero en algunos casos
la célula floyd es se puede desarrollar
en un organismo completo existen
organismos como los dragones de komodo
que se pueden reproducir de forma
asexual mediante la partenogénesis pero
en algunos casos también puede existir
la reproducción sexual
vamos a dejarlo hasta aquí ya vimos dos
categorías muy importantes
voy a dibujar una línea para separarla
así que no se confunda todo lo que
escribí del lado izquierdo son formas de
reproducción asexual en donde
generalmente un organismo puede hacer
una copia de sí mismo
en la misma información genética y del
lado derecho tenemos a la reproducción
sexual en donde para que se pueda
producir un organismo nuevo un óvulo y
un espermatozoide tienen que unirse el
espermatozoide tiene que fertilizar al
óvulo porque cada una de estas células
únicamente contiene la mitad de la
información genética original para
terminar me gustaría dejarlos con una
pregunta que siempre nos hacemos en
biología porque habrá surgido la
reproducción sexual sobre todo porque en
la historia de la evolución surgió mucho
después que la reproducción asexual
bueno un argumento es que la
reproducción sexual produce descendencia
con una variación mayor y si se tiene
una variación mayor en la descendencia
por consiguiente hay mayor variación en
la población con lo que existe una
probabilidad más alta de que ciertas
variaciones se adapten mejor al ambiente
en el que nos encontramos los invito a
que piensen en eso un poco más nos vemos
en otro vídeo